at the end of the film you have a Ryan
bit like a coda yeah very end was there
were you ever thinking about using that
scene to plant a seed for the next movie
or like how did you decide that was
going to be the the ending and was there
talk about doing something else there
yeah there was that you know generally
in these big movies you know you save
some resources because you know like
once you get cut the cut together you're
gonna need a coda that either gives you
a little bit of explanation or where are
we taking this thing right and we needed
a little bit of yet you know exposition
about the virus you know we wanted to
make sure people understood that he'd
taken care of it and was put in a safe
place and our hero's isn't just like
throw it in video sure but like we
weren't we weren't that concerned about
where it was going and just that that we
wanted that it was going to go forward
and there was like hots in Shaw we're
gonna work together again so we have the
coda with Jason and Dwayne and the pub
where you can see that their dynamic is
still alive and we're gonna work
together again and then you get to see a
new sort of relationship with or a
continued sort of relationship between
Locke and Hobbes and that hey Ryan could
be in this thing and that was sort of
like important for me because he was so
good in the pancake have scene and like
so good and like in the way he connected
the movie together you know and I wanted
it to feel like he had an ending in this
this movie as well like you didn't just
feel like such a stunt cast that it's
like oh great they got Ryan Reynolds to
do this stuff the exposition scene
really he takes care of the daughter he
shows up on the phone call and he comes
full circle so he gets the three beats
you know and it's a little bit more than
a cameo
and a promise for something in the
future completely I I that makes
complete sense I think there'll be some
fans who'll be like you know what I mean
like if there was a yeah did you ever
think about planting a seed for the next
film right there you know what I mean or
is it always like that's like the full
circle for Ryan's care it was really
more for me the full circle of Ryan's
character and not like the promise I
mean and maybe the promise that he's in
the future it's not like here's the plot
wrap the next movie you know you know
like and by the way that that would be
the classic sort of thing to do like you
know I got the next mission you know you
know and he does clearly go and my sort
of um we're kind of almost making fun of
that idea because he's like I got the
virus it's a new virus this one doesn't
melt you're outside Smeltzer this one
melts your insides it melts your
outsides you know it's like we're making
fun of our own sort of MacGuffin the way
is I go we're gonna do another one about
a virus but this one melts your outsides
we're almost being satirical in our own
way and to ourselves which is classic
Ryan stuff completely